elles ont la chair noire et les zones
noires des poules faverolles des cochons
gascon et du rock
la ferme de la petite aux gars auffargis
s'emploie depuis des années à
réintroduire des espèces menacées
dans un souci d'élevage le plus naturel
possible eric sanso apparaît en exemple
dans le bien-être animal jeu réintroduit
toutes ces espèces pour montrer que avec
une nourriture commune un espace un
environnement commun on a quand même une
spécificité génétique et donc on a un
goût différent en fonction des espèces
dernière victoire en date la naissance
de deux petits veaux au rock une espèce
préhistorique détendue et sereine comme
toutes leurs voisines des tables par
radio classique que vous dites c'est
dans une dynamique d'échangé de
questionnements autour du bien-être
animal
aurore bergé a répondu à l'invitation de
l'éleveur une journée pour aborder un
sujet d'actualité
l'abattage ici tout est fait dans la vie
de l'animal pour qu' ils soient dans les
meilleures conditions possibles en
termes de reproduction et en termes
d'élevage mais à partir du moment où
l'animal est transportée jusqu'à son
abattage
il ya un certain nombre de questions qui
se posent pour vérifier la traçabilité
la manière avec laquelle l'animal va
être considéré et jusqu'à son abattage
la jeune association en faveur de
l'abattage des animaux dans la dignité
afad était présente pour apporter son
expertise
il n'y a aucun abattoirs aujourd'hui en
france qui est vraiment digne de ce
travail de qualité qui a effectué alors
il ya des abattoirs qui travaillent bien
mais aujourd'hui le niveau il est quand
même largement en deçà de ce qui est de
ce qui devrait être à bout de bien être
animal
l'afad réfléchit à des abattoirs mobile
qui permettrait de supprimer le
transport de l'animal
oui permettant une fin de vie digne et
sereine